a church in southern Spain an unlikely
focal point for the kissing Scandal
that's engulfed Spanish football it's
where the mother of Louise rubiales has
gone on Hunger Strike to protest the
treatment of her son who's under
pressure to resign after kissing the
Spanish player Jennifer hermoso on the
lips following their World Cup win his
cousin spoke outside the church
a friend because he doesn't
he doesn't mom knows like
to know him know who he is this type of
media reaction is not normal he's not a
harasser what is not normal is that this
girl did what she did she was playing
everyone won they were Champions
everyone was happy and three days later
she says it was harassment are we all
stupid rubiales has already been
suspended by football's World governing
body FIFA but the 46 year old made a
defiant speech last week saying you
would not quit and claim to be the
victim of a Witch Hunt falso feminismo
Spain's second Deputy Prime Minister
Yolanda Diaz says the behavior of
rubiales and others at the Spanish fa
has been unacceptable
if I am to give my opinion all those
people supporting Mr rubialis do not
have the competency to remain in their
post those who clap at a violation of
Rights and alleged Act of sexual
harassment a forced kiss it's obvious
they must not continue in their
positions it's all very clear women's
rights are non-negotiable in Spain or
elsewhere
the kissing round was made an impact
internationally including in Mexico City
where Barcelona's women's team is
preparing for a series of friendly
matches
we need to find a solution there need to
be consequences I hope steps will be
taken for inclusion and progress to
avoid this kind of stain on female
football
with this disgusting situation everyone
wants to support her more so everyone
has stood with Spain and with women and
I think this is positive
it's terrible that was power abuse and
sexual harassment during an
international event that everyone saw
the more serious thing is that they are
questioning a player when everyone saw
it and there is video evidence
Spanish prosecutors have now opened a
sexual assault investigation against
rubiales this Scandal unfolding at a
time when Spain should still have been
celebrating winning the World Cup David
Stokes Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera